[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
skimmac consacré à la sobriété
énergétique et pour en parler Joséphine
Colemann vous êtes la mère de plaisir
vous êtes la vice-présidente de 50 ans
en Yvelines en charge de l'environnement
et de la transition écologique alors
c'est vrai que l'explosion des dépenses
énergétiques et quelles ont été les
premières mesures qui ont été prises sur
ce territoire justement pour compenser
cette explosion de d'un facture
énergétique on a déjà fait une réunion à
12 puisque il y a 12 collectivités et
donc on s'est mis d'accord pour prendre
des actions assez fortes la première
action a été d'éteindre les lumières la
nuit donc on a été les lumières la nuit
alors ça pouvait être un petit peu
bizarre oui mais c'était important de de
faire ce choix donc il y a des
collectivités qui ont éteint les
lumières entre minuit et 5 heures et des
collectivités entre 1h30 et 4h30
pourquoi cette différence c'est par
rapport au bus nous allons créer
exactement ensuite on a décidé de mettre
19 degrés tous les bâtiments qui
appartiennent à Saint-Quentin sauf bien
sûr les endroits où il y a des personnes
âgées ça c'était une évidence qu'il
fallait quand même monter la température
à plus de 20 degrés à la médiathèque
[Musique]
moi je trouve qu'il fait qui fait plus
tôt donc ça c'était ce sont les
démarches fortes qui ont été mises en
place justement là et de façon
collégiale avec l'ensemble des
collectivités et puis bien sûr au niveau
éclairage également il y a des choses à
dire il y a des choses à dire et
notamment le passage exactement il y a
des choses importantes parce que nous
avons plus de 38 000 points sur
l'ensemble des collectivités de points
de lumière d'éclairage public et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
changer on est à plus de 25% déjà de
changements et on aura tout fini en 2030
donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant de se
dire que on va voir des vrais économies
avec les LED au niveau des lumières on
va faire le point justement avec avec
Bertrand Cauca qui est le vice-président
de 50 ans de vie dans Charles de Smart
[Musique]
qui va faire le point justement sur
notamment ce passage au LED qui
évidemment
moins cher évidemment bien sûr
sur le territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines
on a à peu près 20 22 % de l'éclairage
qui est en éclairage LED qui consomme
très peu et qui permet d'avoir un très
bon rendu
[Musique]
on va dire un schéma directeur qui était
prévu pour remplacer toutes les boules
qui éclairent le ciel qui sont très
énergivores d'ici une dizaine d'années
on souhaite vraiment accélérer l'année
prochaine on souhaite dédier près d'un
million d'euros d'investissements pour
changer un maximum de candélabre en LED
on va à peu près doubler
l'investissement qui était prévu on
estime un gain total aux alentours de 6
à 7% sur notre consommation globale
autour de l'intercommunalité
[Musique]
entre minuit et 5 heures du matin pour
certaines communes qui ne sont pas des
services par des bus le loctilien de
nuit il y aura c'est déjà le cas une
extinction lumineuse pour les autres
villes concernées par le passage du bus
de nuit ça va s'éteindre à 1h30 du matin
et ça se rallumer à 4h30 du matin c'est
à dire à l'arrivée du dernier bus et au
démarrage du premier bus on est sur une
phase de test qui va nous permettre de
voir de quantifier exactement vous savez
la majorité des gens quand on éteint la
nuit on pense qu'il va y avoir plus
d'insécurité on a déjà fait des zones de
tests qui nous ont prouvé que ce n'était
pas le cas voir même ce que ça diminuait
mais ça aussi important pour pouvoir
s'adapter et pérenniser de passer par
une phase de test
[Musique]
la technologie s'améliore et ça nous
permet d'avoir fait des actions un petit
peu plus ciblées aujourd'hui le long de
la RD30 pour aller à plaisir d'avoir un
éclairage temporaire à chaque fois qu'un
piéton ou un vélo passe donc on va pas
consommer énormément on a aussi des
réflexions pour les personnes qui
seraient à hand visuel par exemple de
pouvoir avoir un cheminement classique
pour aller par exemple au bus
[Musique]
de retour avec Joséphine Colemann berger
pour parler de ce plan de sobriété
énergétique on vient de voir le passage
aux lettres et puis l'extinction des
éclairages publics pendant un certain
nombre de et évidemment d'être au coca
en parler ça pose peut-être pour les
habitants des questions sur la sécurité
est-ce qu'on est aussi sûr quand il y a
pas de lumière que quand il y en a c'est
vrai qu'on a eu pas mal d'interrogations
surtout de femmes qui s'inquiétaient par
rapport à cette à cette cette façon de
faire on a on a aujourd'hui des chiffres
qui prouvent qu'il y a moins
d'agressions il y a moins de vol il y a
moins de cambriolages il y a moins de la
nuit parce que justement le fait que ce
soit noir les personnes qui veulent mal
se comporter doivent elles-mêmes
éclairer donc du coup on les repère
davantage donc c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on a vraiment des chiffres
qui peuvent rassurer la population et on
les fait savoir il faut pas trop
s'inquiéter il faut pas s'inquiéter
alors on va parler d'un élément qui est
très énergivore ce sont les bâtiments et
notamment les bâtiments publics là aussi
il y a tout un plan de d'économie bien
sûr
parce que le bâtiment c'est comme 45 %
je crois de la consommation énergétique
du pays en France et 27% des émissions
de CO2 donc voilà c'est vrai sujet Quels
sont les éléments enfin les mesures qui
ont déjà été prises ou qui sont
envisagées alors ce qu'il faut déjà se
dire c'est que sur Saint-Quentin on est
plutôt par révolutionnaire mais en tout
cas on a bien anticipé les choses
puisque il y a une un décret qui est
sorti comme quoi on devait bien sûr
baisser
toute notre consommation de plus de 40%
et on en est déjà à 28%. donc on est du
jour on est déjà pas mal mais ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que on a aussi voté 9
millions d'euros au niveau de
l'agglomération pour pouvoir accompagner
toutes ces démarches de réhabilitation
des logements puisque il faut
accompagner à la fois les logements je
veux dire par uniquement les logements
mais les bâtiments de
la gare de La Verrière exactement
un parking passif c'est ça exactement
c'est quoi un parking passif alors je
suis pas une grande spécialiste mais en
tout cas j'ai bien compris que c'était
parce que il y avait des panneaux
solaires qui étaient mis en place sur
l'ensemble de la gare donc ce qui fait
qu'elle est indépendante au niveau de
son énergie donc tout ça ça n'a pas sur
les factures mais ça un impact aussi sur
l'environnement et évidemment sur les
immenses publiques
mais aussi un équipement sur lequel je
voudrais avoir éclairage
intelligents oui alors les compteurs
intelligents n'en a mis dans
pratiquement tous les bâtiments de
l'agglomération pour pouvoir justement
calculer ce qui était dépensé et pour
voir réguler ce qui était des pensées au
niveau du chauffage au niveau de
l'électricité au niveau également
informatique parce que c'est important
et on en a mis vraiment partout sur
l'agglomération et ça ça nous permet
aussi de réguler parce qu'au niveau de
départ on sait voilà on sait ce qu'on
dépense c'est pourquoi plus moi donc on
peut dire vous disiez il y a déjà eu une
anticipation mais que c'est déjà sur 27%
d'économie faites depuis quelques années
est-ce que Saint-Quentin puisque vous
êtes en charge de la transition
écologique cinquantaine peut-être une
sorte de
modèle non on parle en tout cas je vous
enroule oh je crois que oui parce que
déjà il y a une chose que je peux dire
c'est qu'il y a des études qui ont été
faites sur Saint-Quentin comme quoi sur
l'analyse de l'air ça veut dire
effectivement comment on respire chez
eux et ben on respire bien on est plutôt
bon sur 50 ans en Yvelines donc c'est
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
très important et on a aussi des
démarches aujourd'hui d'innovation
puisqu'on est une terre d'innovation
faut pas l'oublier et bien nous sommes
en train de réfléchir je dirais à des
énergies propres qui sont les nôtres
comme par exemple la géothermie comme
par exemple des steps ils vont rien
avoir une à plaisir et puis on a aussi
des chauffages urbains dans certaines
collectivités je peux en parler puisqu'à
plaisir nous avons le réserve et pas 10
km de de chauffage et ça chauffe 8000
personnes sur la ville de plaisir ça
veut dire 30% de moins que le gaz donc
51 en Yvelines aujourd'hui est en train
de travailler sur toutes ces innovations
justement pour devenir peut-être à terme
complètement indépendant au niveau de
notre énergie donc on est vraiment une
carte d'innovation alors vous avez
évoquez un peu les il y a aussi il y a
des bâtiments publics et puis il y a les
logements privés évidemment sur lesquels
il faut faire un effort vous disiez il y
a un budget de 9 millions d'euros c'est
ça qui est de voté oui il y a un budget
de 9 millions d'euros qui a été voté
pour la période 2022-2028 de façon à
pouvoir distribuer je veux dire avec
intelligence bien sûr des aides à des
logements privés à des logements qui
vont pouvoir être accompagnés justement
par rapport à des réhabilitations pour
que eux aussi puissent avoir des
économies en ligne parce que notre rôle
bien sûr c'est nos bâtiments mais c'est
aussi la population de 50 ans évidemment
alors il y a aussi la rénovation
énergétique des logements je crois 3
millions exactement l'accompagnement des
copropriétés fragiles évidemment parce
qu'il y a des inégalités
très
forts c'est important parce que les
copropriétés n'ont pas toutes les moyens
bien sûr d'avoir
gérer cette possibilité cette capacité
d'aide donc on doit faire un travail
collectif comme je le disais l'ensemble
de l'agglomération doit être accompagné
par ces démarches là et on a des
organismes je dirais de grandes qualités
qui sont capables de nous accompagner
comme la Lecque qui est vraiment un
organisme je dirais qui est à nos côtés
qui est accompagné et accompagnant de de
l'agglomération et qui permet
aujourd'hui de s'approprier je dirais
des connaissances des sensibilisations
auprès des collectivités des 12 communes
et également de la population pour leur
dire comment fonctionner et comment se
faire aider c'est l'agence locale
d'énergie et du climat mais justement
Jean-Baptiste à Monique et votre
collègue mère de mille vice-présidente
délégué au transport et aux mobilités
urbaines nous explique comment on peut
bénéficier de ces aides de la Lecques
aujourd'hui quand vous voulez faire
quelques travaux sur votre logement vous
ne savez peut-être pas comment vous y
prendre vous ne savez pas par où
commencer et donc avec les équipes de la
lettre il y a des conseils qui sont
proposés sur les matériaux sur le type
d'isolation qu'il faudrait faire en
priorité sur les différents appareils
qu'il faut changer
[Musique]
on a besoin d'accompagner sur le terrain
je prends l'exemple des balades
thermiques les balades thermiques
permettent de se rendre compte que on a
parfois des logements qui ont besoin
d'être réhabilités qui ont besoin de
bénéficier de certains travaux
il y a aussi le conseil sur les aides
financières et c'est souvent là où les
particuliers ne s'y retrouvent pas
puisque il y en a une multitude je pense
à ma prime rénove je pense au certificat
d'économie d'énergie sur l'année 2022 la
lettre A fut apporter plus de 3000
conseils
[Musique]
la création de cette association s'est
faite sur le territoire de 50 ans mais
aujourd'hui le périmètre est beaucoup
plus large beaucoup plus étendu on
travaille avec la communauté de la Haute
Vallée de Chevreuse on travaille avec
Versailles Grand Parc on travaille avec
un certain nombre de collectivités
d'interconnalités le parc national aussi
régional le PNR ce qui permet d'avoir un
rayonnement auprès des particuliers sur
l'ensemble de ces territoires mais aussi
d'accompagner les collectivités si on
prend l'exemple de Saint-Quentin l'ALEC
a participé à l'élaboration et à la
construction du Plan climat énergie donc
elle l'a co-construit avec
l'agglomération ce qui montre aussi que
c'est un acteur qui est en
accompagnement des politiques publiques
locales portées par les élus
bon on vient de le voir avec
Jean-Baptiste Monique il y a beaucoup
d'aide qui sont proposées aux propriétés
aux forces habitants de logement il y a
aussi ma prisme par l'État il y a habité
mieux comment on peut se renseigner
auprès soit de 50 ans soit des villes
aussi pour savoir comment marche ces
aides alors ce qui est bien c'est que
toutes les collectivités sont très au
courant de ce qui de ce qui se fait donc
déjà les habitants peuvent se rapprocher
des collectivités et aller directement
faire une demande pour qu'on puisse les
accompagner et bien évidemment 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est exactement la même chose
donc je crois que ce qui est important
c'est de savoir que dans chaque ville
vous avez des élus qui sont des
référents de l'environnement de la
biodiversité de la transition écologique
à partir de ce moment-là il suffit de se
renseigner dans les villes pour que
chacun et ben puisse trouver je dirais
l'aide qui lui convient exactement ça
c'est très important
là on est dans un domaine où on utilise
des énergies qu'on connaît déjà il va y
avoir aussi là aussi il y a des
inventions il y a de la l'innovation
dans l'énergie comment comment on peut
imaginer un peu de la ville de l'avenir
justement moi j'aurais tendance à dire
que ce qui est bien c'est que
aujourd'hui toutes les richesses que
nous avons déjà qui sont des richesses à
la fois agricoles parce que même dans
l'agriculture il y a des récupérations
que nous pouvons faire pour pouvoir
créer justement et bien de l'énergie
nouvelle il y a également dans les
collectivités aujourd'hui des des
recherches qui sont faites dans le sol
pour trouver de la chaleur avec la
géothermie et puis on a aussi et bien
des usines d'incinération et bien on
jette nos déchets là-bas et avec cette
chaleur et bien aujourd'hui nous faisons
de la chaleur urbaine l'économie
circulaire exactement et on espère bien
et je le redis encore une fois avec
force et que 50 ans à terme devrait
devenir et bien je dirais voilà autonome
au niveau de notre énergie et ce serait
un bien pour la population et aussi pour
notre planète ce serait une bonne chose
merci infiniment
et merci à tous et on se retrouve très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de ce qui
mag
[Musique]